[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning everyone welcome back to
GameSpot live
I am Ritchie and I am here with Ben
today hello finally
yeah happening we're finally on a street
you know this is it and we're playing
the disintegration technical alpha isn't
it
yeah or maybe let me double check I was
like I'm not sure if it was the beta or
the Alpha but it ate a test of technical
beta technical base so we're a little
further on than I thought initially but
it's an interesting situation a game
that's being made by someone who helped
to make SOCOM US Navy SEALs Halo Coco
that one of the co-creators are hailing
yeah
so that might sum things up for you
about what we're about to get into but
as we play I'll read you through the
website but Ben Janka will be playing
some multiplayer for us today so how
about we jump right into it okay yeah
let's let's just let's just go rightful
just go you guys so they've got the the
whole setup is is you get kind of like
these these anti-gravity bikes bikes mix
and girlie up some gear man yeah there
are different teams and they all have
different weapon loadouts and different
aesthetics yeah we were talking about
those like something for everybody here
yeah I've been I'm actually been using
the games I played I was using them a
little bit earlier so they've got like a
shotgun and like machine guns
nice real straightforward but we can
mess around with all of them I was like
lasers I had one I think I picked that
guy and he had like a really cool like
crossbow laser thing maybe that was
someone else but uh had a good I had a
good first run when I tested this out
this morning just to make sure
everything was working out but I am
ready to jump in when you are dude only
matchmaking okay do multiplayer because
it's a technical yeah the campaign area
thing was like just grayed out it wasn't
an option this morning so hey we got
some love for this game already so cool
this game is gonna rock we got some fans
already hell yes guys so we although we
can't play the campaign I'm here on the
website and there's a brief synopsis of
how it goes down it's basically that
scientists have taken human brains put
them in robots and that process was
called disintegration
it was supposed to be yeah and [ __ ]
started hitting the fan and cool this is
like in the near future they're saying
after extreme climates overpopulation
and food shortages that probably will
not bleed into the multiplayer here but
that's the environment that's the
setting we're in yeah and what kind of
match did you play this morning the
style I played was like domination style
so I played the domination one and I
also played like a weird one-sided CTF
type of variant which I think we're
about to play okay so there are like
three points on the map where you have
to grab canisters and your units that
you control because you you get these
robots that are behind me uh-huh
and you kind of like RTS control them
around and tell them what to do and they
actually will pick it up and you have to
escort them all the way to okay okay I'm
glad you played that mode because the
only one I played was domination and if
I had the control of my head and be like
a pretty lost but here we are then that
is on the stick let's go so we're
capturing so got you baby it's weird
because every when I was playing me too
and I went I snuck and took seed by
myself like people aren't spreading out
as much but it's very early and we don't
know the layout of the maps but we do
know how to play domination
got some action going on there we go
they're attacking did no one
we're running we are playing on PC too
so I might take it as an opportunity I'm
playing on a controller right now but
this this closed beta was available for
all of office I believe then you were
playing it this morning on the
PlayStation 4
[Music]
yeah
Brandon in the chat good to have him
back he says this is giving him
titanfall why did the whole MEK and
these big-ass maps
meats it's a lot of like MechWarrior and
like a small game on the Xbox called
battle engine Akula I don't know anyone
in the chat but it's basically the same
kind of set of brief got these kind of
like floating in the next
that way it's pretty smooth I mean I've
noticed though how like in these big
mechs you can't go fast you get little
boost to go left right forward and back
but you can't like you know what on the
ground though they're moving the same
speed maybe he just seems slow because
we're in the air so you got the core
we've got to get them all the way over
to this spot where our friends already
fighting ok go and defend him so for
anyone joining in thank you so much for
being here
we're playing disintegration close beta
this game was developed by a small team
of 30 people including the co-creator of
pillow also maybe so go pop baby seals
yeah we got some pedigree here you got a
good team oh good it's all good yeah you
can't stay alive oh no wanna die
something the very first time I was
playing this morning I got kind of
wrecked and then I was like okay wow I
cannot rush in this game it also kind of
makes sense carrying one of the
objectives oh right you were a target
for sure
Roboto in the chat says it looks like
anthem okay yeah this is a bit of like
yeah a caution the chat welcome back man
he says my only criticism of the game so
far no dying blacks yesterday we're
playing when it dies so none of that
here today unfortunately sorry
but thanks for coming back
there are classes they're sort of more
like character based class oh my god I
can switch to a different industries can
we just play twisted metal oh my god
twisted matter I love twisting yeah you
know what this reminds me of like the
2012 twisted medical suite two rounds
yeah yeah
Evangelion color scheme love it oh yeah
you were like is this it oh okay so he
only has one weapon okay yeah hopefully
those little sticky grenades do some
damage oh they're part of the foot
soldiers I kind of like this I played
with the character who had a cool like
laser crossbow
yeah like that motorcycle guy yeah
Wow a lot of damage whoa dang the clown
guys like the sleeper player me
Roboto in the chat a big fan of twisted
metal
hell yeah
I know that's another series I'd love to
see come back Oh didn't what zero
puzzlers your rounds but now I think we
switch and we have to defend interesting
but they just looked like the time right
now no one scored points yeah I don't
know
oh oh there we go here the rest of the
that was pretty apocalypse this looks
like it's got a long cooldown oh and it
looks like it might cause some real
damage so no I mean it does it looks
like that condition did I hear it like a
car starting up like your engines are
like starting up I think so see the
aesthetics are also in sound so that's
pretty cool I love that exterior like
engine thing that you got going on like
Dom Toretto is a charged army and try to
catch people as they come in this way
he's kind of quiet
how we doing chat
hello
anyone here yeah Kosh monomorphic got
the crossbow yeah that's a pretty great
troll weapon I got it the first day it's
pretty fun but I can stick with it hope
this isn't like lawbreakers mmm Corby I
still feel really bad about breakers
yeah I in all like ways that the game is
a good game just man
said a lot someone else or the chat yeah
I forgot about I forgot all about
lawbreakers totally forgot about
lawbreakers lawbreakers I just think
like Casey Jones from noodles you know I
like one like the first two weeks that
game was out I yeah I feel like the
whole office did and then you know we
can drop some ass for lawbreakers in the
chat
oh you think going away oh I don't know
if I are you doing good though you're
keeping your distance
sure yeah oh nice Oh Bradley there's no
offline mode yet the the campaign mode
in this tactical beta is not available
there will be an open beta yeah but for
now it's just online multiplayer match
me
there's running
oh geez where's the rest of your team
all the guys paralyzed no oh there you
go charge it up maybe I don't know how
that gun worried it looked like you it
was like charging up yeah look cool I
was like all right this is it you had
new sights lined up it didn't look like
it hit him though and then it was like
core yeah yeah all right so that was the
first I don't I believe you did your
part you did the best you could
yeah everyone learning that these these
these cool robots are probably the best
bet because I got that shotgun and I got
that machine gun mm-hmm real real
straightforward yeah we just got to
figure out who we like the best yeah
that clown one was a maybe the clown was
really pretty cool because you could you
could blow the the bombs up in the air
mm-hmm which I think was a real real
good clutch that is cool oh those guys
on the ground warrant a I write you
played as one of those foot soldiers
before I don't I don't think so I think
you just kind of arch he has him around
like a mortar interesting okay cuz chat
was asking I was like no I haven't been
one of those I don't know if they're AI
but I yes I think you you kind of just
give them orders and they oh yeah when
you press the right bumper you had like
a marker ability like go here no this is
not titanfall cue Megazord ask him
although we're getting those vibes for
sure this is disintegration is made by a
small team of the 30 developers
including some people from Halo and the
SOCOM series yeah this is their first
game it's not a triple-a title but it's
got like you know the grounds for one
just give these neon guys ago
there we go you got this it's gonna jump
on see yeah this is a map by play
transformers like junkyard here okay
he's looking good yeah we're in here
David in the chest as this hand looks
like mask you know what it's really
early right now
so hard
yeah oh this is the guy I used to like
he has those uh those mini guns but they
they need a car down
these drums are thumping peppermint to
me misguided emotion these things nice
there we go we got beat
nikasha no we haven't played is all the
characters yet when you got it like a
lot of them this may be Ben's liking
this folks
oh I also if I click the right stick in
and you got like this lady like humans
eater it's like that's the aim down
sight or something like that
Oh
wait that was that was a good match so
you've got a lot of people what's
fueling it yeah or at least you
inflicted a lot of damage those guns
right yeah so I feel like he's a little
bit quicker than that's good yeah I like
that little boost you can do that I love
dodging shots oh there you go oh you got
him I love it when something gets so
excited
whoo
if you guys are interested this is a
there's an open open beta coming up
this integration website
don't tell me that like Iron Man yeah
don't tell me I know the bad
[ __ ] what time what you think it's a
thing we're trying to fight me over just
trying to survive he was just trying to
cat be or were you guys at
good student look
aha delivery I think this guy might
specialize maybe pizzette that those
machine guns
now I have to make you scream like that
yeah
uh well yeah here we go I think this
guy's hyper rifle okay yeah it looks
like what he's holding like some sort of
like don't be charged rifle or something
this thing's a cosh also says in the
chat this is giving him transformer
wives - definitely
this looks like the set of Transformers
- the movie oh wow shotgun bang
nice
well how do you feel about this I like
doing maybe more like a bull rifle or
like don't see secure oh this is like
viewing gun okay I stay your mercy on
where were our support
what platform is will this be on it'll
be on just about every console except
for like switch right click for Xbox ps4
Oh
yeah they're like a melee that you go no
it's a close game you know see defeat
hey someone wrote we got some Gigi's in
the upper left there titanfall 3 no
similar I mean it's looking like that
all these big max this is disintegration
I did much better with them I did
previously nice got some chest rigs yeah
good stats here I also I don't know if
there's a way to like back out and just
start no I couldn't it was like again I
tried that to like look at your staff
yeah this is holding you here for
another 5 seconds it looks like the game
just mm-hmm
it doesn't want you to back out or if
you do it'll go to like the main menu or
something there we go
this is even some appearance mods
a wake says so halo wars in first person
my boy that I'm into it what most FPS
players walk backward anytime they shoot
at something I think it's because you're
kind of like doing an offense and a
defense at the same time it mentally you
feel like you're safe for stepping
backwards
mm but in all actuality you're probably
not there specially with how slippery
everything is in this game yeah it
depends what gun you're being fired at
with you know like the spread of that
gun if you backup you have a chance of
dodging somebody just like probably more
of a reflex and anything yeah but there
are a little boost mechanics in this we
can like boost left right forward and
back to this game also feels like it
would kind of go straight into like a
circle strafing each other the whole
thing yeah that'll probably be mastered
shortly and then just be circle strafing
you're totally right is there
customization you can mess with the
colors at least from what you can see in
the beta but not too much outside of
that there you can do like emblems and
stuff for your your like player card
Semih said I should play more shooters
minx
do you friend let's go with the support
again nice your arms look like graphics
cards with wings I do like I think it's
the strongest thing about the game so
far I've seen is just the characters are
pretty cool yeah Brent go bot soldiers
where is your help there you go I was
like you late
damn it's a little weird I saw all those
shots hitting there will be a campaign
China's asking yes it's not in this beta
it's locked for the beta but it's
planned there's only some matchmaking
options right now for the technical baby
so and be lost so this is the one that I
like - yeah that's the very first one I
use I had some good luck with it but I
know I'd rather have like full auto
hookahs spray-and-pray or myself yeah
pretty bad
you're making them though you doing
great yeah I should probably focus on
new that guy whoa I thought that was a
shield lately I'm good feeling there at
the same time to come sounds going on
soon yeah
there's a little travel time on this too
man we're like in the middle are we here
a point or were this one behind us okay
that's why I think Justin is asking he
only fight in mechs or can you go around
and control your pilot so that would be
nice
yeah I kind of wish that it's not
appearing so like those little foot
soldiers I don't know that's not us we
haven't done that yet yeah I think the
REI he'll your pranks
well yeah getting out and controlling
your your pilot would be pretty cool
just as an option anyway
there's a fight going on foresee I don't
want to like leave our point that we got
yeah
the struggle man the struggle of Dom
it's like now it's the fight for B yeah
I don't see getting too much in the way
yeah no is there a class progression
system or is everything unlocked from
the start I haven't seen anything me
either
it is early on I don't know if it's even
implemented in the beta if there will be
one but we have there's no sign of it
yet it'd be interesting you get like
different loadout system
yeah no there's nothing happening over
here and as soon as I do someone's gonna
start capturing that but want to mess
around more with these characters
let's see what we can unlock the edge of
these uh this characters there's just
more experience I guess oh man they're
holding down at B oh oh god I'm stuck in
a wall again no Eli says we need more
arena shooters like quake but this game
seems to slog yeah it's it's a little
little slower than I like it to be so
I'm gonna go back to my my cool neon
guys yeah that guy looks yeah oh I did
not know that he is about to win the
Koch asks that we play t ee d saints and
sinners
whoa it's like in my own like you were
getting like this
Dustin says well to be honest I like to
give most games a try yeah but if
there's only met control I'm not sure I
would get it it's fun but a variety
would definitely make the game more
replayable that's just my opinion he
says yeah you know what you know we
appreciate you giving it a try - I mean
that's what we're doing we want to get
our feet wet with this game it could be
something great or we can just you know
you know maybe not but exactly and that
goes for adjusting to it same thing you
just have to try it out at least make
your own thinking about it yeah I wonder
if there was like a list it it kind of
threw us into like a random playlist
though the available games I know that's
what I was not looking forward to that's
why I want to these are better than last
I mean yeah that that night guys
interesting he's also a support but I
don't know if I am I'm with that
crossbow thing exactly ah me either I
wasn't good I'm just I'm no good with
like single shot charge weapons in the
like there's something to be said about
how much the like when you're getting
shot by multiple shots from like a
machine gun it actually like shakes your
screen and stuff and it's roll yeah Gary
that's when I thought you were getting
EMP I was like what's wrong with your
screen it's just like fizzling out yeah
let's keep it going
ready go here x1 that guy's patiently
waiting he's got those octane legs
oh yeah mech arena I totally forgot
about that
Oh what I'm psvr it's it's real Oh got a
real similar setup make arena it sounds
familiar I don't I don't have a psvr but
I mean I got an oculus oh nice so I
messed around with that a bit but
there's some ones on
but I really do like VR stuff like I
kind of thought it was kind of like not
not a big thing sure until I I got my
own hands on like my own headset on
restaurant like oh okay yeah I feel like
there's a lot of like like the software
isn't there for me yet but the the not
exactly there's some standout exceptions
Resident Evil 7 was fun
there was another one I forgot what it
was called it was one of the first VR
games I played but it felt cool like I
felt really small what game was a god
damn I forgot oh well I probably will
never remember me and Nick margaritas
streamed it won that one time far far
for something oh my gosh you're right
there but yeah it was that was cool yeah
there's also a lot of trollee fun games
for VR which I want to get into maybe
I'd like appreciate it more if I played
those games a lot of small developer
games oh there you go he's got a VR chad
is like an interesting fallback yeah oh
I never played that I just saw the memes
I came they the the interesting thing
about it too is they made it she could
play it with or without a headset so you
get the experience but not the full
experience
Eli's as a symptom admittedly
distinguishable
Dustin is asking if we ourselves are
joining the beta
what's on it like there's something cool
there but yeah I'm in the same boat but
I've only played one match myself and it
was just like this actually
numerous fun to be had I want to put
like more maybe but I also want small
variety in the pamphlet
there you go that's always satisfying
anytime I feel like I'm out I gotta kill
her just reeling you back in
cheerio cheerio says lawbreakers lines
oh yeah discuss that for sure
also I will forever be haunted by the
fact that my top two likes team oh
really oh that hurt
I know that feeling
a rare achievement on my entire steam
profile
whoa that's that is cool
oh dude in the chat that's his name dude
like it
he says the game lag for him on xbox
yeah thanks so on on ps4 there is a lot
of
Oh father is dissipated
that's true and fortunately for today on
stream the PC version seems to be doing
Oh
[Music]
oh yeah and you got oh we got zone a
that was a lot happening at those like a
climax right there like the apex of all
the action in this this might be the two
guns are very good don't be secure
it matches yeah this is just first
person yeah I'm figured out either I
don't think there is one Devon yeah
welcome back
Devon joined answer the past today howdy
Alvaro Lee is that titanfall no we're
getting those vibes for sure but this is
not titanfall as it is disintegration
game made by some former Halo developers
are one of them like co-creator of Halo
and part of those
the other game like Navy so competent so
fabulously sad so on another developer
come back serious is also involved in
this game to know
oh did you have you know I didn't have
online access for the ps2 days did you
Ben did you play games online right
I just I wasn't into that mindset yet
and playing online I played a lot of
like single-player games on the ps2 I
feel like I missed out
I almost had it fool no I missed I was
looking at chat so I wonder also if like
shoots so I felt like I'm that guy who's
expose the person that I am if I shot
weak spots any interesting there's no
indication
Eli in the chat asks we play as the
people on the ground no it doesn't
appear like it yet either that's like
you know not available in the beta art
stuff gameplay mode that we can figure
out yet there are there on our team
there little AI
where to go but
at least we can't seem to figure that
yeah you can ping there's a there's a
ping system to like you know point of
enemies are so I thought that it was
just oh really okay so you pointed at it
Anita's over so if I find someone I can
like hey protect that guy okay which
seem to actually look pretty well
Susy secure dude says I hope this game
gets a horde mode
okay Thank You Ashton I will turn down
the game volume a little so that you
hear us
ohad okay he was updated on the chat we
love that feedback we need that feedback
for y'all one of those fun games where
it seems real quiet until you get in the
game when it's just gunshot yeah that's
also probably not a problem with this
game but uh actually happens with a lot
of games yeah for just the spike in
volume out of nowhere I think we won all
right just gotta stick with that that
bike the whole time that's our guy
you know if there's any loot loot
campaign mode I have no idea no man we
can't get our hands on campaign mode
it's been blocked out for the for the
beta but it's there it's planned but we
don't know much about it yet yeah I mean
rest see if a lot of that like Halo
SOCOM influence might come through in
the campaign more mm-hmm that's what I
was hoping to play to be honest like I
wanted to if the campaign was offered I
wanted to jump into the story but for
the beta it seems to be only online yeah
yeah which is fine you're talking about
Nick little earlier what is right here
margarita in the chat giving us pro tips
yeah yeah ah I really I really like this
this team though this is this is the one
I'm gonna stick with them they don't
have names huh what's this guy's name
what's his deal well I think it's the
crew night neon dreams
oh that's the crane crew dreams teamwork
makes the neon dream work I do like how
quickly the matches are filling up
though yeah we've had no problem with
that I don't think it is only uh oh
nevermind
there we go ten out of ten time fallen
flight simulator I'm excited for that
new flight simulator that looks real
good
Oh what's he call it was it wasn't just
called flight I think it's okay cool but
they got that advanced mapping
technology in there it's looking real
nice I don't know man
maybe it'll you have a fear of flying at
all Ben I mean sometimes when I'm in a
plane I feel uncomfortable but that's
just because somehow we're defying the
rules of how everything works I've got a
giant metal tube flying about a little
overwhelming me for the most part I'm
not like afraid of flying I guess same
here I get a little antsy if the flights
too long but in general I'm okay on a
flight it's a combat mainly mid range
are there any shotguns yeah the the
other one that I was using these guys
they've got to like submachine guns and
a shotgun so you can get more close
range with them but I feel like this the
this one is a real good kind of
mid-range setup so that might be why it
seems like that nice DK in chat what up
dudes hey hey how's it going thanks for
joining us will there be a public crater
you're talking about one yeah let me
double check there it definitely is one
this is like a close one you had a sign
up for it on the open one I believe is
like in a few days like maybe even on
the 30th but you can sign up at
desintegration game.com
I'm on their website right now going for
it you got it
will do
of course I'm not seeing it here anymore
hey if you go on the website you can
sign up I'm pretty sure I solve a
thirteen but later this week the open
beta will be available
whose high heavens whose nice
I'm out of here
Nick in the chat be on the lookout for
some campaign bills zoom oh right yes
and thank you yes the open beta is
running from the 31st of February pure
sure says it looks like something from
the tooth that early two-thousands not a
bad thing remember that one game oh my
god we were playing it when it was
re-released wolf metal wolf chaos oh
yeah that game just screams the route
thousands yeah it's but I loved all the
games that people decided to bring one
back into current times man did you play
that demo because that was only a
Japanese exclusive I think this was
unlike a demo subscribe okay that's how
I played it - in the office I didn't
clean her I only came out Richard you
know what I'm buddy
trying to
that made the cores out as far as the
final release date of this game I don't
have any details on it for now the
website is just promoting the Nevada the
open beta coming up soon
you know what I'm just gonna just in
rumors Justin in the chat just yelled
the game is so funny alright let's take
it got some people up ahead
that's always a good sign they don't
look like they're stressed out too much
nope
there's making their way oh here we go
nah hey he made quick work of that guy
he deep-felt
right into that whoa oh there's blind
low trying to stay off the radar
come on in yeah
that's war doing it it is we that you
have to score by taking it into the air
so I guess that's part of the fight
yeah that is a little different huh
there we go no one's that a man this is
your chance let's grab this one - nice
follow I killed someone nice
are you guys you're all damaged oh
you're not the healer guy huh yeah melee
combat no I don't think we're seeing any
I try to have you tried I tried like
every button to see if I could like Carl
punch or like you know I don't melee
who looks like a like a mainly century
yeah with a brawler guy
Oh Jew hello come out of nowhere
No he's all exposed out in the middle of
the road that's like you're one soldier
now my dude oh there we go got some air
control oh yeah [ __ ] on Futurama
remember how they kept moving yeah yeah
the heads into the future and they kept
them preserved in little canisters who
it is you know oh that's how I could
tell but he has a different color scheme
it was like why didn't he lie on the
chat says the bullet the enemy seemed to
be a bit bullet spongy I think different
characters have different health going
critical
Oh
that actually has a
all of my people are dead Wow
hey your team sports okay that's fine if
they'll take the extraction for it
that's all I'm heli is yeah noticing
there's dats up there on the top left
like that guy's durability was low but
everything else he had good stats
otherwise
one minute remaining ashna's says this
game likes uh seems like it would be
good for xbox game pass hey man that's a
deal
yeah xbox game pass is doing no wrong
nice soon you get this last score we're
just gonna rush it come on boys let's do
this
Brandon is playing as Joker in Mortal
Kombat 11 while watching our stream
doesn't say jack you know I love his
coming out correctly reforged came out
wasn't that all like today or yesterday
like within the last - yeah it's just
everything just decided to happen so
yeah this - we had a like I remember we
had a pig later this way to talk about
this yeah well that's fine I mean we got
the rest of the week
tries mother found
one more core all the times almost done
from there he's almost there come on oh
you're an OT you're at ot oh come on
show yourself my sweet beautiful robot
boy brought it home shut it out three no
or three zio they've got to capture
three to be able to tie it up oh man
I've been in these matches before they
could come back but don't let it happen
characters that are better for defense
offense to I of course not paying any
attention to that because I just want to
play as my my sweet mixtape robots oh
you hit the cassette player he's writing
a cassette player what's the thing with
this game so the we were reading a bit
on the the history and apparently it's
in the future they decided to put
people's brains into robots to preserve
them yeah didn't work out for all people
but they're in robot bodies yeah it's
the the deep lore we've got a sort of
bit of an understanding
this is from the website it says that
process which Ben just explained is
called disintegration and the website
says it was a good thing for decades
allowing humans to survive some of the
integrated saw this new form as a future
of humanity
geez going to screaming yeah there
there's a lot going on there Mad Max
over here Oh believe it
see oh they can just go back to the
business yeah yeah they're probably
better for for defense cuz I got a
shotgun and people want to get up close
together yeah and his durability seems
to be higher like you can take more
damage Marty says this games been flying
under the radar I remember seeing
something about it a while ago and I
forgot about it alive well you're at the
right place my friend
this opposed beta is going on for
another day and then the open beta
starts on 31st so if you like what you
see you can sign up actually you don't
need to sign up for the open beta in a
few days so just be on the lookout for
it though it's a cross consoles and PC
aughter says he played some of this at
Gamescom it feels better than it did
there but still little robert yeah this
is where you give your feedback you know
play it
I'm sure there's gonna be a survey tell
me what you think
and Brett Davis his let's play titanfall
2020 we're getting those vibes for sure
but not quite
by the way I love your user name and
picture this key on America your
breakfast
mmm-hmm see what happens
oh there you oh I'm back God eliminated
okay they're not a one guy listen what
the heck that was pretty funny to see
them like run and like literally the
opposite direction
Coba Cocina says this game has no ground
combat yeah yeah okay good to confirm I
mean we we were trying to figure that at
birth there you go yeah I'm not even
doing things and I'm just
there's murder how your squad is killing
it man yeah before they call again this
team I forgot the business
motivation and hustling the SATs as I
wish there were crowned combat yeah it
shake things up a little bit you know
I'd want to try it for sure I thought I
was like the first time I played I was
like oh sweet I got randomly selected to
be the mech guy but it's like oh no
you're always the mech guy yeah they'd
be an interesting take on it actually a
few we've got a few more people in the
servers and people had to like no one
poking holes in here yeah like not
hearing a no way that like if you put
down a
still doing damage I don't know what
that okay that's shield if you run into
it I think you get hurt right
we go
I can't believe it see I don't think
I've actually played as this one yeah
see if I can give it a go
there we go this beat is the one of the
fastest oh heck yeah that's what we need
yeah need for speed so yeah rockets and
cannons and a lot more health sweet go
to the other side cos there's no one on
be doing alright like defending all this
yeah I think you take this dude you
don't flick damage on the building it's
all a little hit marker is some swag
stuff
we got two warriors and a striker nice
just what oh it's this yeah probably we
talked about that earlier in baby it'd
be a cool option to like get out of the
mech or maybe play as the ground soldier
Jaden says Wow when over watching
titanfall get the docking body else
there - like what it tells you you got
him like you were taking out says you
were disintegrated yeah by so and so
high for doom eternal very Akash you so
hyped more than oh my god there's no
word to describe how I tie him to be
returned oh I was able to edit some
gameplay we have it's on our GameSpot
gameplay page there's a glory kills
compilation for doom eternal and which
then we collaborated a little on that
you were like hey can I can we get some
BFG divisions by gordon mosley BFG
division like Layla's yeah so there's a
good compilation on our GameSpot
gameplay channel and there's also
another seven minutes of just gameplay
it's
I'm willing to meet you
oh hello all right great
that's fine oh let's change it up again
did anyone mention that room to came out
Satchmo room room room I hear a lot of
people like bloom I haven't played it
myself either but it's got kind of like
a like a hack and slash RPG kind of
setup to it
oh cool it looks mean I'd like to try it
eventually
rip and tear until it's done yeah by the
way this is bang we nailed it
who's been genka be one and only it's me
I'm here playing video games if you want
to catch more mean I usually stream on
Fridays john luke and i woulld oh yeah
we're playing by Liv and smash oh shoot
so yeah if you want to play smash with
us please come on by on Friday mark your
calendars man yeah but you should be
here every day Monday through Friday we
do that promo we stream every every
weekday at 11 a.m. Pacific you should
come and hang out we'll play anything
beta's previews games that we just like
I like that a little bit of everything
yeah we just kind of hang out with you
it's a good time let's go again what are
we listening to and it's cassette player
II by the look of him I'm probably say
something like out like a deaf Punk but
it's like yeah like out like a MIDI or
like yeah some of their very early work
that was only released on cassettes
there you go some EP stuff definitely
what are the game modes might just be
the two oh yeah there hasn't been
anything else retrieval and zone control
because the the two challenges are for
winning three rounds of each Oh wonder
what you get for the challenge complete
well those points right you got a dist
integration points on the top right it
looks like you made some more oh yeah
more points to get more more cool
appearances I love your school when
you're that like neo neon guy like you
have that squall posted up staring at ya
oh here we go
which character you like playing in
smash i I try to play as many as I can
but I usually will fall back on to snake
I like DDD because he's super
disrespectful they with Wario yeah I
like like Donkey Kong I like messing
around with Wario I like banjo because
even though he's not like the best I'm
just really happy that characters in
that game like when what I'm what am I
most competitive I'll probably be
playing a snake nice Wow
so like I've never really played a snake
so much I love snake but I I figured it
was like sonic words like that it's a
novelty they put him in but he doesn't
control very well would you say snake
controls I think he does that's cool I
I'm really into it he's he's got this
really cool feel to him worried like he
has to I feel like he has to be like two
steps ahead of anyone in the middle of a
fight oh you've got to put c4 down and
you've got a control space with like
Rheneas to kind of force people to do he
just those little are they like small
range grenades like they don't go very
far they've driven they can go pretty
far okay so you got three different ways
nice but I like him a lot they did a
good job
cool he's voiced by David Hayter yeah
it's all good by the way the announcer
of this game who just started the game
sounded like Big Boss oh man sorry I'm
sorry boss
I always forget her name she does the
voice of pearl on SpongeBob
you probably hate that I said yeah but
she has such a unique voice yeah I have
a plate smashing up in a while like but
I I always like playing a Samus Samus
yeah this is classic you know I
oh I don't know fact whoa nailed that
I'll just say it
what about you guys who are your mains
and smash by Terry No - Terry there's
really cool that I know was for soccer I
because He loves us on K games but yeah
listen he was so much really good music
more of that
yep Zeno in the chat the robots on the
ground Rai that you can direct a little
bit like an RTS but you control the ship
correct
come on Kosh says Pikachu that's how you
play smash P she's always a good time
Little Mac I feel so bad for furlough
Mac because he's he's probably one of
the hardest characters to play in that
game so my god I know like the main
symbol of soon as they're really into
him yeah it's like close close quarters
or like nothing it kind of it's if you
know what you're doing you can pull it
off but like I'm always cheap and I'm
like pushing him away with my samus
blast like get away cuz I know if you
get close you're gonna knock me out the
ring he hits so hard but he's nothing he
can do in the air which is super true to
his character and really cool man
motivation we will be back on Friday to
be playing smash so you can join us then
but when you're located in the SF office
here in sunny California although today
it was rainy it was raining so full
we're out here yeah if you do want to
know whenever that happens it is this
Friday and if you subscribe to the
channel you'll get sent a notification
whenever it goes live or any of the
other shows go live so you don't miss
yep but it's every weekday 11 a.m. and
we should have I think Jake said he was
gonna be on he's like our big night guys
yeah sure metal against him yeah
come prepared he's real big up into
those firearm characters oh man
the right guy for the job I'm over here
doing cross the mat come on I hear you
pressing the booze button boom oh just
barely
fire flying castor says sounds it looks
like an interesting game that could have
a cool multiplayer community but I don't
know if there will survive I don't know
if it will survive as one and myself I
will not have time to get into it well
you know what I would give this beta a
shot there's this is a closed beta but
the open beta comes back on the 31st
maybe confirm your feelings about this
game yeah it's kind of it's straddles an
interesting line but I feel like if I
were if I were to feel comfortable
recommending it to anyone it'd probably
be like MechWarrior fans yeah absolutely
but at that point like MechWarrior fans
can't pull them from it I'm gonna try
this out oh that guy below
oh you're going for the big cheese oh
okay so maybe I'm kind of like Lecter
will apply at a certain time or
something
Oh we'd launch out of your control
I saw it though like if you shot he
fires up whatever projectile or the
laser
currently this uh this beta is
free-to-play oh there it is
but the final game I don't think will be
whoa this is the guy that was giving you
trouble or what'd you say
are you there it is oh yeah I got the
assault shop so you have to let go
but it might cause like it cuz it's it
says it's a warhead yeah I'd say warhead
yeah baby and the chat what's going on
zero says we need a better MechWarrior
Online yeah your thoughts what's the
latest like I'm not in that community at
all five I've kind of just fallen off a
mech warrior I see oh oh that's why I
can't move there's someone on top of me
Ruby those games Armored Core
yeah that's Philistine those people are
making Dark Souls now oh that's right
whoops yeah do you think they'll ever
make another Armored Core that was a
like a sleeper hit the whole series I
liked Armored Core I like the style of
Armored Core a lot mm-hmm
it's uh I like to see anyone I keep
going back to them hey there's a little
fortnight dance I could play any of
these people but I just wanna be always
it's definitely the coolest welcome back
Akash hurry time about like arena
shooters to earlier we're last night
we're like man it'd be nice if like that
unfinished Unreal Tournament game made
it through like we got a new proper
quick cuz quick champions was
yeah kind of like okay let's put it this
way I kind of forgot that that happened
it was an interesting idea because
you're just at one point
can't say they didn't try
I liked it we actually had it I liked
those days
so to catch up on anyone who's just
tuned in we are playing the
disintegration closed beta this beta
will be an open beta on the 31st and yes
you can get it on Xbox ps4 and on PC if
there is it's weird that we're actually
pushing them
and you've got a person's actually oh
that's no I should probably just please
[Music]
there you go one two action but that
other guys are like this bugging oh I do
have some
there you go charge it up
you like paralyzed that guy stop moving
I don't say I am disruptive does
[Music]
[Music]
sure the
fool for not knowing hey we're all
learning yeah that's a good question
once you meet someone with the cannon
right Bob Jones is asking and like thank
you how it just doesn't make like a
massive explosion out thing because I'm
sure you've landed into that they cannon
she was a long charter Florida yeah it's
a bit of yeah I've been hitting people
with you can tell because they like
right yeah like that hit that with some
final boss stuff which makes me think
that it
[Music]
yeah like them or something cuz I it
seems like people kind of like
the game I try to like
oh that was yes Akash there are no dying
quacks in this game birds are dying
screams which is even more unsettling
there you go well I'm trying to show my
friends that I know what I'm doing oh I
think you've got that if we lived away
it was around here areas flying low oh
he's almost down yeah
Bonzo more like dunzo
very good
oh no definitely be hasn't been oh it's
way abandoned we're going critical
you know it's about time someone say
oh thanks anytime yeah prom cap
Vikas wishes we could play that pump
while this in or listening to a song
while we play this yeah you know there
is no music I wish there were some I
don't know you know I'm thinking about
other first-person shooters that don't
have really music either maybe it's just
uh I think it's you can hear what's mean
because the other games I play like COD
their sound design is like whoa almost
too much it's overwhelming good Russian
music oh
how high can you fly a Staubach high
it's like using left bumper and left
trigger I believe ya make you go up and
down but it's like this is the extent of
how high okay that's it right there okay
tell me that doesn't sound like boss I
wouldn't be surprised
oh I'm killing people cool there you go
interact with RB unless they all went
over to P dang yeah it's kind of quiet
over here so this takes place in the
near future they say Oh
nice shot there you go oh you fell out
of your mega ragdoll physics Wow
[Music]
there we go there's some tuneage
rats my doom has great music oh my god
anyway for Doom I feel I feel like I can
safely say I don't know if any of the
doom soundtrack is gonna be better than
pfg division free but I know I'm gonna
prove wrong it's in Douma turtle yeah
when you go to that training there's
there's a small training stage
auditorium the Ripper thank you yes and
that just plays on loop forever there as
you fight everyone all I want yeah that
oh my god that song specifically I
remember when it the doom soundtrack
dropped
unlike Spotify I was like oh this is the
best day just the whole time yeah it's
like a nine minute song like the full
version is belong it's great
there's someone did a really good kind
of documentary or like a like a thing
explaining how the music is designed in
that game I watched it too that's so
it's real real smart he uses like
old-school tech new school tech guitars
with like eight strings on them
distortion pedals like yeah that fill
the size of this room it's crazy me
Gordon is a genius wonder what'll come
after Doom eternal doom forever
oh no forever in the name it's not gonna
be delayed yeah right doom forever
though that beat oh well doesn't have to
be the fourth one what are you thinking
four three then doom infinite infinite
warfare yeah yeah yeah we've got the
fourth one figured out it's not easy
yeah we need three we're already there
how we're back in the junkyard
yeah we're also doing a lot a lot of
planning around doing doom eternal for
Friday's - just because of the the
invasion stuff oh my god count me in for
one of those next thing I want to be a
part of that is it'll it's gonna be good
with like just be like hey this is our
game find us come and try to kill us yep
this is your chance to finally just all
team up on us it's got a gripe with
GameSpot come settle it and do yeah yeah
no our chat love that's right guys
holdin it down at seat is his own
control is a good thing that's mix it up
with number coming a slow Chuck see it's
right there so that guy's still really
low on healthy oh there's a little foot
soldiers running away
I want to be that guy
ground patrol it's not an option though
whether you've learned
only try and check out my dues no that
was the first mistake Bob Jones is
challenging people now I see no more we
just want to be doomed
it's just the excuse point doable yeah
I'll be honest and join us anytime we do
so it's the perfect setup for playing
anime fighters all right we need our
leader fix
my gosh love grandpa Richie and Uncle
Ben yeah I got called that I don't know
she saw that stream then oh you know I
forgot what it was but me and David were
posting yeah I got called grandpa Richie
I think it was Tim time a while back
because I'm an old school Pokemon fan
and so I just kept making fun of her
yeah exactly I can make in that job and
we called him young and young and Danny
Falls and grandfather it's really good -
after do maternal ivote for a quake one
remake alia oh my god other sick we
could
yeah
yeah Jack tried this out maybe the the
open beta there's a closed beta that I
don't know if you can get into anymore
but the open beta you don't got to sign
up and it starts on the 31st so I hope
you'll be proven wrong to hope you have
some fun with this game but try it out
for yourself that's what that's what
it's all about today
that's good thank you we're at least
more comfortable with this now yeah whoa
don't do this to me that boost quarter
and let's come on your guns
oh he's escaping he's like oh I'm sorry
can you hold on for that long
don't die already there we go nicely
done you Henry James down good all part
of the plan that back down there was
like pink and blue looks like a little
diva man the grenade oh cool all right
we have the lead but they're going for C
it looks like B is under trouble
oh no I use the one of the swords
through it
then as soon as you left a someone went
there
the nose I've seized Oh see okay be it's
hot right now with the heck what's the
guy who chased us you probably know
whoo
again god ohh ohh Julio dad that sound
like a race car game you know they loved
those announcements in those like Sega
Saturn racing games cool
Akash Asik we played Terminator
resistance
I've not played either like
he also says I heard they have the
kick-ass terminated
yeah disintegration sorry oh dang God
that's what we need to bring yeah that's
117 asks if all the gameplay is in the
vehicle yeah we it's all mech based like
there are ground soldiers but they're AI
they're our friends and we can't be them
it seems he's controlling tell them what
to do yes call the shots but we're
always in the mech which we're mixed
about that we want to kind of want to be
down there yeah I always liked
oh that scream did get cut off those
like
Oh can't believe this
mr. hotrod over here - yeah so hard and
got so far it's okay Ben in the end it
doesn't matter doesn't really matter
that's what you say oh gosh I'm gonna go
for it again go for it god I remember
that video house eg heavy it was like a
whole weird movie it was a fun time I
was just about to say that yeah
although it was weird I think back on
that video fondly that Linkin Park video
yeah good times
you got this yeah all three points so
shoot oh it's hot at B go in o lovers o
they shoot they were like no no sir
you're in the wrong time you put the
wrong little engines dang yeah I want to
be that guy
like a whipping Sam thanks
yeah what the heck then that has to be
like that like the damage Bob oh wow
yeah that poor him off
akaash says imagine flying this thing in
real life
I don't know man one time though I
thought about like what it's like you
know GCA how fluid it felt to control a
helicopter yeah I was like wow what if
what if helicopters were actually
controlled and controlled that way yeah
like I could do it yeah I know I
couldn't do I could get low 5kd yeah
I'll take you all right nice dude
yeah getting better and better just
gotta keep at it yeah wish these points
went to like stats or something doesn't
mean to be a progression system in
[Music]
killer stats right there zone Street 50k
total damage damn that's so much damage
there's so much damage that's your guy
right there then that crew it's killing
it damn I've never heard of actually
that's not true I was gonna say a 4 a 4
5 KD and anything but there's been that
lucky streak that lucky match of cod or
whatever worth like whoa I whooped ass
so the one where you accidentally went
like 28 you got all these kills and you
didn't die once right nuke dumb man
going in again oh wow it's it's 12:20 oh
wow we have ten minutes that's pretty
even realize I guess this might be the
last match would you like to me yeah
okay yeah yeah I'll give it a shot
I want to like take the whole thing from
you no it's fine I mean we have it set
up so you can play something you played
a little more than I did but uh well
I'll get into match here sure I was I
was like man maybe I should pass it off
at some point I totally forgot I'm like
no big deal but I just uh yeah thanks
for thinking of me let's do this I'll
give it a shot hell yes this is just
titanfall says cows are I'm saying
definitely we got those bytes for sure
can't deny that and this guy's getting
impatient for this yeah is that boy okay
move him around he did that little
fortnight dance earlier to do that I
think you just all when you select oh
yeah okay here we go transformers more
than meets the eye robots in the
junkyard did you what yeah I'm thinking
of the movies did you watch any or all
of those the ones or the new ones the
like the Michael Bay ones i watch past
decade like the first me too that's
where I think I stopped yeah yeah then
like they recruited Mark Wahlberg am i
tripping and like one of the last ones
with bump mm I don't know how about you
just watch those movies bumblebee was
fun it was a nice that what I did watch
that I know uh they had that that guy
from the Las Vegas showed Josh Duhamel
oh yeah using them also in college in he
World War two yeah it was like here's
your commander or something weird to see
like him in that kind of gritty game
yeah I I enjoyed the campaign for World
War two me too
I loved the multiplayer too that's what
that brought me back Cod for a while for
a long time that I was obsessed with
that game here we go hear that metal
creaking yeah I gotta get my feet or I
gotta get in control here oh three
seconds okay it's not bad on the
controller although I'm I'm I'm more
keen to controller for most games myself
if there's a PC port I play it for like
the enhanced graphics but I'm always on
the controller that's just me though
furgus benefits from being on the
controller but it probably play really
long it's weird like I have a you know
if I played what did I play like GTFO on
PC because there was no controller
connectivity and like my wrists hurt in
a different way supposedly hurt me like
here felt like I was like geez boy am I
out of it
it did with the flim-flam whatever
testing out my oh this is the clown guy
with the grenade guns already in the wow
look at that great was all right how do
I use the other gun Keith David doesn't
modern warfare 2 I love Keith David's
best role besides Halo poops friendlies
I'm here at be were y'all at ok this is
a beyond me going up where they go
they're running away yeah you got out of
there okay well we held it down at B
that's what matters to me number one Ice
Cube was in black ops yeah that was cool
Bowman yeah we all know his fate oh snap
it is oh shoot admire your ranger for me
look I've got it then how do i fire that
other weapon I have impressive oh why oh
I won't lift it Wow okay takes a while
doesn't leave your gun right away yeah
you're right here once there is an
explosion cool I'm about to die oh no
it's reloading this thing that doesn't a
lot of charge time alright I think I'm
toast here really oh cool okay let me
get a little Spacey oh [ __ ] I'm still
I'm still in their sights quit shooting
me oh no nope you didn't see me they
didn't see at all goodbye it is going
back up okay we do a loop-de-loop here
and bring back around bring it back
around bring it around
excuse me sir while I have you here oh
it's the cloud the cloud
I totally whipped it I'm trying to get
more help but you're going so big
wow it's like delayed but like that's
pretty cool hey who's shooting me these
are my friends okay time to go to Zone B
apparently it's under attack yeah yeah
okay enough with this gun we're gonna go
back to oh shoot I went back to the
wrong gun it's going off over here I
like that last time the first match I
ever played earlier this morning was
like you're about to lose it wasn't very
nice to hear
come on oh-oh-oh happen they did we just
launched one of these onto the ground
I'm still looking charging up though I'm
losing help again spraying me dude oh oh
yeah Prakash I did the loop-d-loop and
pool and my mate blew the F up switch
crews I don't want to switch babies oh
but that's a choice this is just an
option here we go oh I thought it was
that guy for a second I was like wow he
glitched we've done it we've done it
come on four minutes left for the stream
anyway this is gonna be yeah we can have
a nice long outro okay oh wait wonder
what the hell am i doing it
seeds wait no does that see oh that can
take it look there's a little bit of red
here let's just claim see all the way
please tell me that's what I'm doing I'm
not getting any sort of visual
confirmation
okay hmm defense mode let's get out of
here then
come on BOTS nail that we won perfect
excellent
dang Wow that was a pretty clean match
yeah but you guys were winning like
literally responding really yeah did I
jump into a late game no I think we all
started new right you're there yeah shoo
well that's a good high note to end on
yeah
just switch over here back to us look at
that
here we are thank you guys for joining
us today we all try it out
disintegration there is a closed beta
going on right now I don't think if we
have access to but if you are interested
to play the open beta is on the 31st for
Xbox one Playstation 4 and PC so in the
meantime thank you for joining us well
we will be back tomorrow we stream every
weekday at 11 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
until then appreciate you tuning in and
we'll see you next time bye-bye see you
later